so in last night's show and on previous
shows we've told you about the cases of
two men
julian assange and john carraku julian
assange is a kind of
international journalist john carrick
who's a former cia officer we should be
totally blunt and tell you we're not
sure we show the politics
of either man but both of their cases
tell you something
really important about what's going on
in this country about what matters
and about what the people in charge
would like to prevent you from doing
julian assange and john carricku both
went to jail for telling
the truth neither one stole classified
documents from the u.s government
neither one of them
hacked into anything julian assange told
you a lot about what the u.s government
was doing abroad and told you
everything about what the dnc was doing
to rig its own primaries back in 2016.
remember the wikileaks dump
you know about that because of julian
assange and by the way if you're a
bernie sanders voter assuming any of
those watching tonight
you probably were glad to know that
everyone else was lying to you
julian assange brought you information
that you had a right to know
john karakou meanwhile told the truth
about what our military and our intel
agencies were doing
during the iraq war again you may not
agree with his
position but what he said was true and
that matters above all because truth
is and must be a defense if you say
something true
you shouldn't be punished because we
should value truth above all
in both cases those men went to prison
and in both cases tonight as one of his
final acts as president
donald trump has the opportunity
to make that right to pardon both of
them we told you that last night we told
you it before we're hearing tonight
that neither man particularly julian
assange we don't know if this is true
is likely to get a pardon why
well apparently because republicans in
the senate and by republicans in the
senate we mean mitch mcconnell of
kentucky the leader of republicans in
the senate
has sent word over to the white house if
you pardon julian assange
we are much more likely to convict you
in an impeachment trial
now is it legal to hold that over a
president's head we're not lawyers we
don't know it's certainly wrong
but more than that it tells you
everything about their priorities
at a time when this country in some ways
is coming apart we're at a pivot point
in american history
and if you're watching this show you
probably feel pretty threatened and for
good reason
there are people on the other channel
saying they're going to hunt you down
like a terrorist
at that moment what is mitch mcconnell
your designated defender in the united
states senate worrying about
he's worrying about protecting the
uniparty in washington not his party
his party and the democratic party in
permanent washington
they're the reason both these men have
been locked up because
both these men embarrassed permanent
washington
that's their crime
and his priority in the final hours of
the trump administration
is to make certain that they remain
punished for doing that
it tells you everything we don't know
what's going to happen in the end we've
got a number of hours left for the
president to make that decision
but we want you to know how that
decision is being made because it's
deeply revealing